hey guys I'll to go and I'm Justine
welcome to the Internet this behind me
is the best video I've ever started to
watch I started watching those like oh
my gosh I need it for my reaction
because it's so cute that I felt like my
brain was going to explode this is
crispy bacon he is a little pinky who
was born but too little back leg cuz it
didn't really work but his owner came to
the rescue and made him some little
wheels for his back legs out of boy
parts I mean it just so joked okay guys
ready to watch Chris he was born without
the use of his hind limbs oh my God look
at his long face like I seriously he's
just gonna like as pigs are seriously my
favorite freaking animal we'll get him
I'm low it's my dream to be crispy is
the P stand for what do you guys think
Holly call somehow look like he doesn't
even need his little wheels look at that
little piggy face I could look at him
all day
hold on taking a screenshot because I'm
making you my background piggy you okay
he thing he said he's looking at me cuz
he knew I was taking his picture I want
to take your picture
if this guy did a good job I mean he's
got a freaking little harness he's got a
model wrapped up first be showing what
you got show him what you got what you
really really got he's really not is
just kind of sitting there now I can't
wait to see crispy as a big PE he's a
little piggy that could what's that
little snack oh my gosh Len I don't know
how to pronounce your last name Lucy ro
Lucy Len Lucy ro you are very kind
Sewell a lot of people think pigs are
dirty animals they really only roll in
mud because they don't sweat I've
actually known people to have pigs as
pets in their house you walk in where's
your dog oh it's that's a pig that's not
a dog it's a pig in your house as a pet
Louise getting nude crispy drink the
milk you're thirsty you been wheeling
around all day you got to get the only
going this is like breaking and warming
my heart Chris we good the Mook what you
know about rack Rack City rack Rack City
look how cute I want another screenshot
look at him he's so strong krispies like
peace out bro peace out bro I'll see you
on the flip side Lenten go get him and
we'll see more this is never gonna get
all to me I just are looking up little
piggy videos on YouTube the end no that
can't be the end what else we have Len
what else do we have
pig without me on and off there's only
three videos only three more milk
krispies you thirsty what else we got
going on here still drinking still
drinking piggy cute all right give me
another video what else we have time to
play show me more like
he's so cute look he's like I know these
are for me I'm just not big enough to be
in them he's like hey daddy can you pull
me my big boy wheels now Len
congratulations I love your pig I cannot
wait to see more videos like and
favorite I'm liking every one of these
come here like I do favorites
crispy blowing on my feed I love crispy
okay no beanie caps piggy dreams love
you xoxo xoxo xoxo accept anybody that
doesn't think that I replied in my own
garments or reply to any comments trust
me I spent a lot of time I hope you guys
enjoyed this video as much as I did
because it is seriously the cutest thing
in the entire world if you guys enjoyed
it make sure you hit like don't forget
to subscribe so you'll see the next
video that I post and if there's a video
that you guys would like me to watch
next make sure you leave it in the
comments below I love you guys and I
will see you soon of course most
importantly oh my goodness how can I
forget but we'll check out freaking
Christy Bacon's channel because he's got
a couple other videos of his future big
boy wheels my god is so cute can't even
think I love you guys bye is so excited
so yesterday I found out about this
contest where if you win you can go
through space I don't know I'm so stop
talking and play the game don't spray
stain